it's not an alternative very widely
said yes that at all freud ya 10 200 which
is why ndiaye said he this cheater
security and stability andy murray then
a canteen or discussed form
finally platform for politics jean
claude
nicol footing nkou wi fi nit drop on
the gif format to the leader only and win tin
all said faletau specific sco willy
chiefs liable first meeting in by
nearly 1 to 2 Czech taking a continuation of the
news people to dead to do with the
french president de cech rotating
presidency 10 possible meeting  after
summer today it's by the way this
weekend yes ok I don't find procrustes in everything
who post from the heart indicates a
deflationary situation but jack and
the fall of the soul of greece ionis
pushing up angie foot center politis n o
f10 and those confused  impact during the
citizen business is why united n
swissgrid whose claudine is in cannes
hamid by the crs 26 1 cent peak
before looting a political thorn fan shop
rakitic
women committed to complete in dub
itunes to a stats sheet will
follow 22-10 full heart of capital
markets in women's priority we
also had the opportunity to
once again address the progress that needs to be
made in terms of
energy issues with  the firm intention to
continue with little effort to
coordinate our actions in this important area,
also taking into account
the work carried out at the start of
the commission, finally, two
specific points that I would like to mention
is the significant step forward
by the  croatia to join the
euro zone it is an important decision which has
been endorsed by the european council
an implementation will take place in
the next few weeks and the next few
months and we would like to warmly
congratulate the authorities and the croatian people
for this decision which shows the
strength  and the resilience of the euro zone,
finally, a point that also concerns
greece since we had  the opportunity
to welcome the step forward made by
greece in terms of the end of the
reinforced surveillance program
it also shows the
significant progress that has been made
and then it remains for me to mention two more
elements on the one hand once
again  to say our thanks for the
French presidency of the
European Union have an opportunity at the end of
the European Council to salute all together
with the twenty-seven leaders the
gigantic work that has been brought together has been achieved in
legislative terms but also in
political terms in the various
dimensions  and the efforts will
continue since in the
next few days still by stubbornly demonstrates
the question of the western balkans
and north macedonia
taking into account albania taking into account the vote that took place
in the Bulgarian parliament a few
hours ago I have no doubt that we  we will
remain very very hasty to try to
progress on this subject lady but once
again a huge thank you to the president  dent
and all the teams who have been
mobilized to move the European project forward
and then there is to give me a
particular, more personal message about
pineau this pinot and pineau so it will
actually arouse a little bit of a
little bit  of surprise perhaps but
pino and then we are
institutions for the press room the
notoriety is international
[Applause]
and I wanted to thank you from the bottom
of my heart and I see that the
applause shows the affection that
they have for you  brought a huge thank
you to you in this case thank you very much thank
you thank you
[Applause]
thank you sir madam
is due to the continuous efforts rainbow six
title titles i hold up east
of
the
impact
of the stars ping
imagined stock markets
plays there
adapts to difficult conditions
a
green energy it offers us here resort
&
gas here
allergies their history pine
nuts union aap
gesture
news
egypt and
when you're
lookin  g at ​​home in your dog sitting
dating
figure europe in you know what it is by
50 the artist marc from globalsign
all alone concern for big four
avery their
design
and no rick hansen
by emmanuel bail commercial and intensive new to
and extremely
everyday  yoichi wada will i
want to thank you want put in
time
from your friend stream and jan alston
in to die
in
line with
death by many gauche and to buy
machines
from
sony
[Music]
hunt this for women but also known for
emmanuel frot
thank you madam  Chair Mr.
Chairman You have the floor Thank you
very much Thank you Mr. Chairman
Madam Chairman A lot of things
have been said I will not go back over
the debates this morning which were
held The conclusions are clear and
I believe that Chairman of the Board the
president of the commission have clearly
traced the nature of these debates aimed
at providing an even faster response
to the energy issue and more
broadly of course the subject  that we
are experiencing an
accelerated return to inflation
normalization of monetary
policy on both sides
of the ocean and we can clearly see this from the
first signs of
economic slowdown all of this is creating a situation
that requires us to take measures
rapid decisions on several subjects
whose energy is to continue
to implement the major
structuring projects to make our union
precisely stronger stronger more
sovereign more united on
the budgetary and financial level I
would just like a word in the margin if
I can say from what President
Michel said a while ago about the
European political community to say that
last night's debate
after the press conference that
we held I believe really allowed me
to enlighten and build a  very
broad consensus around
this theme
it is not a construction a
process which is a substitute
for enlargement in any case but we
have all measured  re is first of all the need
to have a political framework in Europe
to be able to deal with
strategic subjects and we have seen
that enlargement in a way
given its pace
given the conditions does not exhaust
everything that must be  a relationship between
Europeans and therefore this
European political community will allow
the scale of the European continent and therefore
in a very open way on a basis
I would say geographic and value but
from Iceland to Ukraine to be able to
bring together partners  who would be
subjects of defense and
energy security of infrastructures
of health crisis economic solidarity
will be able to discuss structuring themes
that we will have to prepare and it has therefore
been recorded that the first meeting will be
held in the Czech Republic within the
framework of the presidency  to come with all
our partners and with a desire
like that to have a relationship between
equals and therefore to
gradually structure this approach taking into account
ten  u of the
obvious interest that it takes
from a meal would also come back
we mentioned it yesterday but the news
this morning made it evolve on the
accession negotiations with
north macedonia and albania in  Indeed
I would like here to
congratulate the vote today of
the Bulgarian parliament which opens the way to the
lifting of the Bulgarian veto and the opening
of negotiations with North Macedonia
and in doing so also the progress of
the Albanian file in the next
hours we  we will continue the
technical work that is necessary and the
exchanges with our Bulgarian and Macedonian partners in
order to formalize an agreement
in the very next few days and I
would say that the machine is ready here to
then
fully endorse and implement
what could be decided so c  is
a very good signal and I want to thank
the Bulgarian Prime Minister but
also the forces of both his coalition
and his opposition who were able to
unite around this vote and
also thank  seasonal normals for the
late hour there is still work and therefore
we must not declare victory too soon but
it is an important progress
I thank you, Madam, President
von der leyen for the point that she made
on this semester which  allows me
to say that all these advances I will
come back to some of them would not have
been possible without the complicity of the
hard work president michel and I
thank him as well as all of his
services from the president and
the commission and its services and the
european parliament, to whom I
also want to pay tribute, who have
worked tirelessly the united institutions have been
able to act during this semester
because we must all
recognize with great humility
the europe of june  2022 is very
different from that of January 2022 and
we had not anticipated it at this
point obviously with and above all
because Russia decided to launch
a war but because if we
acted united  a series of
extremely structuring decisions for our
continent sanctions with
unprecedented speed in two days for the
first series of sanctions with six
packages with AIDS sanctions like
those taken during the last council
which seemed unthinkable six months ago
no one
I believe I can  say we ourselves
could not have envisaged that we were going to
sanction 90% of Russian oil and
we did so powerful macroeconomic support
for Ukraine both its defense and I
also want to salute the decisions that have
been taken in this respect by activating the
European peace facility and by
showing that we also know how to
put ourselves in a position to be able to help a
country that is entering a war for
our values ​​to equip itself in addition to all
the bilateral support that has
decided on this point and then
macroeconomic and financial support in addition to
the financing and reception of
refugees and what has been done
both for  r better welcome them and
integrate them into the labor market, as you have
reminded us, and help the countries which have been, if
I may say so, on the front line, I am thinking
in particular of poland, romania,
hungary,
in parallel with all this work and this
context, we  we were able, if I may say so, to
complete this one
by yesterday's decisions and the very strong political gesture
of our europe with regard to ukraine
of moldova and the
european perspective also given to georgia
but besides that  we moved
our agenda forward
because this agenda, I believe I can
say, was also very consistent with
this geopolitical change and therefore
did not see the war coming and
we had to take massive decisions
to deal with this conflict,
but it  has only strengthened,
accredited, and validated the conviction that
they were at the heart of our work,
that of a need for greater
European sovereignty
more than ever and this sovereignty
which seemed  another two or
three years a wacky French idea
which was then allowed to build
a real convergence of views
I believe that we have all measured
the importance of
technological sovereignty,
defense sovereignty or
European energy sovereignty this crisis has
accelerated this war in europe has
basically accelerated our collective agenda
and therefore that we have indeed been able to
advance a number of files during this
semester
we have been able to buy your advice on the
implementation in terms of the fight
against global warming 2
several consequent elements in
parliament therefore the establishment of a
carbon tax at the borders of europe
in the council a tool to fight
against deforestation through our imports
we will work until the last
second so that the member states
can adopt the  set of texts
that will enable us to achieve our
objective of reducing our emissions by 55%
by 2030 on many  p
for this subject here too I would like to
thank all the institutions for the enormous
work done, we are not far from being
able to complete almost
this essential axis and therefore the next few
days will again give rise to intense
technical work and negotiations on
the  social europe plan here too the
commitments made have been kept with a
major advance on minimum wages
so that European workers
can live with dignity
on their wages and put an end to the
race to the bottom, which is
consistent with the  battle that we had
waged to better regulate the work of the
tasks and on that we were really able to
be helped I want to thank the
Portuguese presidency which had played a
very big role during the social summit
but we have cleared up all the
misunderstandings that could have been the
differences in models that had between
us to complete this text and then I
also want to say our satisfaction
Madam President mentioned  é to have
finally been able to
complete this progress for equality
between women and men in the
boards of directors of
companies
for this text there it had been blocked for
ten years and therefore collectively by the
game of new coalitions also
we were able  advance it on the
regulation of digital giants here too
we
have built strong progress together with
the two European laws
of digital markets and services which will
make it possible to regulate both the game
of players and avoid the phenomena
of hyper concentration but  also to
better regulate content which is a
new fact we are the first
space to do it and as we had
put in place general regulations to
protect individual data it is
a step forward we are not at the end of
the road there too  I say this with
both great pride that we have made progress
on these two directives and
great humility because there is still a great deal
to do if we  we were able to go all the way,
but we were able to begin to impose
on the major digital players respect
for competition on the one hand and the withdrawal
of racist and terrorist hate speech
on the other a lot of other
legislation or little progress
on sovereignty to our  borders
with the schengen reform and the
unprecedented progress on the
european asylum and emigration policy because
we have collectively chosen
this gradual approach and therefore it is
true that our package, which is very
ambitious, the
commission's proposal  I have always said I
strongly support it, but we have been able to
make progress on many subjects because
we have decided on this gradual approach
which has allowed us and quite rightly should have been
better protected to better filter
entries at our borders better
distributing the reception effort to
preserve free movement in the union is
a first structuring step forward in
terms of defense with the definition
for the first  e time of a
strategic roadmap for the
next ten years and the commitment made
at the Versailles summit to
strengthen our defense capabilities and
investments here too
it is a historic step forward and it is
the culmination of the work  which had been
launched under the German presidency
strategic compass and it is very consistent we
arrive united as europeans at the
madrid summit at nato to defend its
positions in terms of
energy sovereignty by deciding in versailles
to accelerate the reduction of our
dependence on  fossil fuels and
to diversify our sources and
supply routes to
reduce independence with very structuring first choices
of joint purchasing, among
other things, and in terms of
economic sovereignty with instruments to
protect our public markets from the
aggressive strategies of certain
major powers  with advances
in the direction of a more
responsible capitalism and for better
finance  ment of our economy can I
say here how much, beyond neighborhood issues,
the advances that we have been
able to make and to which we came
back yesterday, the partnership
with Africa has also structured these
last six months and the summit that we
have held  with the African union
February with therefore we are one of our
partners has made it possible to build a
renewed but advanced method on
subjects that are also very structuring and which
have been confirmed over time, I am
particularly thinking of the subject of
food security in  cooperation
of a protein strategy
but many other subjects in
particular in terms of financing
allows us to finally move forward
Europe will not be a power just
by listening to its citizens and the
conference on the future  of Europe
initiated in 2019, officially launched
a year ago, this work was submitted on May 9
and we now have
to grasp these
profound transformations that the  france supports as
you know for a more
powerful daring protective europe and on
this subject we have had the first
exchanges and we will continue in the
european council here are the few words that i
wanted to see here to say how
much indeed during this semester we
we reacted quickly and strongly to the return of the
war on European soil but
at the same time
we pursued our agenda we
consolidated because it also demonstrated
I believe its great coherence with the
geopolitical context which is ours
I want to end with  a word to
thank i thanked all the
institutions but the french teams
in brussels as in paris for their very
great work because the
thanks that you attributed to
me are in a way for the storefront
and i have  tried to push to take the
things that belonged to me but there is a
huge work of the ministers of their
team but here to really find a
permanent representation  between all
the teams and in paris the teams
also at the elysée in matignon and so I
want to thank all the
French teams for their tremendous work
and their commitment and in a few
days we will pass the baton these
few days will be  still
very busy at the presidency therefore Czech
and I want here to wish a lot of
courage to the prime minister péta fiala
and to the Czech republic I will have
the opportunity at the end of the Madrid summit
to officially pass the concrete in any
case we were very  proud very happy
to be able by your side to advance
all these subjects and build a
stronger europe thank you for the great privilege of
working alongside you sheikh sharif
sheikh that
thank you sir we have a lot
of french press with us
naturally
I will give the  word first to
mr mathieu couach from bfm after
quite rare from
jérôme good you have to choose me i have a
question about gas you mentioned
measures  of a song in July
so do you have any
information that russia could
completely cut off the tap in
the next few days or
weeks is what measures that are being
prepared will affect businesses and
but also maybe  individuals
as are considering from germany
now and for france is what
you are sure you can
completely cut off will you pass russian gas
dc dc winter
is
that the streak only by
because life
and feelings
[Music  ]
[Music]
gas
national but also local and national
market adam scott a very bad
two singles brand of surf bad to look
into
effect
in fine she is
the only date in france
and
it was
for example
now for france
the  Prime Minister and Ministers in
charge of energy explained the
strategy is haunted indeed by
giving visibility and on the fact that we
would not have a problem
like you  you know france depends little
on gas and it suddenly depends little on
Russian gas and we have built strategies
for precisely diversified but this
approach has a meaning that is limited because
in fact our market is integrated and
it is the  gas itself
or electricity our markets are
interdependent and therefore 6
there was a strategy to
completely cut off Russian gas the difficulty
will be very great and the pressure very
strong on several member states and
therefore that is why it  we need a
European strategy and the same
for electricity and there we need it
because depending on the day France
either exports or imports electricity
it depends on the faith of our needs our
production capacities at a given moment
and therefore it  is very important for
all these reasons that we have a market
that continues to function so we
need to have this strategy of
diversifying the
supply of gas supplies as we
conduct it I am a  great advocate
of the name further strengthened European coordination
with all colleagues
but besides that we are
also accelerating the transition to reduce the share
of gas in electricity production
which is very consistent with fit for
fifty-five the two together the
best  short and medium
term policy
giovanni in the next you confirm
the great interest in the
italian daily avvenire so speaking
of energy i wanted to know if you
also touched on the issue
of price caps the price cup and in particular
for  madam president
of live you were elected to the
last european council
as if we are of course returning to
explore the possibility of activities of
having to place kate I wanted to know
when do you think of
presenting your opinion this will be part
of his plans  that you have already announced
for July and finally if, like the
previous one, you talked about presenting this to the
leader, that means that maybe  maybe we
can see a new meeting of
July leaders to discuss this thank you
topix has
concluded
indeed
[Music]
we are all log in to curb
add that we actually had
the opportunity to address all of these
subjects he concludes  would also be almost
completely the link with the will
through our international partners
on a subject such as this, as
you know the debate has once again made it possible
to highlight a
very strong will expressed by many
around the table d  accelerating efforts to
try to act together act together
in the context of purchasing
energy resources also act
together in terms of in terms of
storage and then, as you know, once
again voices have been raised to
encourage the  look at
the electricity market in particular this
question of the impact of the gas price of
gas on the price of our city it is a
confidence is expressed towards the
commission to continue to work  ler
on the subject of confidence also expressed
for the Council and French France
now Czech who will be
responsible for coordinating the actions
of the various, particularly with regard to a
European Council I confirm
that indeed we are supposed to
have these debates again  after the summer
in the month of October there is no
decision taken in any case for a
council which would intervene rather
simply as is the tradition we
follow the situation a motorbike round the
situation is otherwise the
various institutions there  understood at
ministerial level will be mobilized under
the authority under the direction of heads
of state and government
virginie malingre du monde hello
yes hello i have several questions
the german government is weakened
that of mario draghi also in france we
do not surrender  still well account of the
consequences of the results of the legislative elections
is what you think so this
question is for you that we laugh  sque
of suffering from a lack of leadership in
western europe at a time when that
could pose a problem for gas
for you, madam von der leyen, you
talked about
diversification, i would like to know, we
imported into malaga about 150
billion  cubic meters of gas
today between what was concluded
between the united states and israel etc
we are at how many billion cubic meters
of gas we can count on
first billion cubic meters of
gas which will replace Russian gas and
then  i have one last question
about minimum corporate taxation
hungary bloc have you
discussed this with viktor orban is what
you plan to do by the end of the month
bruno the mayor said he would
try to unblock  the situation before
the end of the French presidency so
where we are thank you thank you very much
perhaps on the third question the
diagnosis is very correct it is
hungary that is blocking we spoke about it
with viktor orban
so  we are going to do everything both
Europeans and non-Europeans involved in
this agreement because I remind you that it is
an agreement that only took on such a
broader state platform and many are
interested in Europe moving
because we are linked with the
American agenda and with many others who
have signed so we are going to do our
utmost to be able to unblock
this Hungarian veto at this stage which
is indeed the only point that remains where
the other subjects have  been clarified
with the other member states so we are
going to do the maximum but as
allow me to be stoic in the
matter as in everything that does
not depend on oneself we can commit
reasonably but no more
on the other hand I can  engage
reasonably on your first
question and tell you that all in all we
cannot at the same time consider
that our europe must be a
democratic europe is strong and and deplored the
fact that most governments and
of parliaments reflects the
democratic vitality of our countries it has
happened that I have been criticized for having too
much power because majorities are too
clear France is in a
parliamentary situation which it experienced
in 1988 shortly  many things of difference but
it is above all
terribly commonplace at European level
on all the member states there
are about twenty which have
coalition governments and some
with five six seven partners
or others which acted without a
minority government so  I don't believe for a
single second the question
put to us by all European leaders
in countries we can clearly see where the
world's divergences, sometimes the extremes,
show what we have also seen in our
country
go from building compromises in order to be
able to convince  everyone
anyway the maximum to obtain constructive majorities
and therefore I believe that
this is what pushes us itier d'aude my
colleagues but that is what Italy
like Germany  basically it's what
we'll do what we'll do and
with all the government parties to be
able to build either a coalition or agreement
on texts to move forward on a
clear agenda so i think that
europe has leadership but  I think that
all of us must be very careful not
to oppose leadership and the
constraints of democracy
because otherwise I can cite
leadership that is much clearer than us,
but they are not democratic, but I
believe that these models are less fruitful.
that ours and moreover we were
able to see it when we managed the
health crisis which urgently requires
strong decisions many countries
have made decisions outside the
democratic system they have turned out to be much
more false than us because we have  no
more controversies we have sessions in
parliament that last longer
than others with him too that allows us
to move forward so I will not put the
political complexity of our countries in the
situation that our continent is experiencing and
the effectiveness of European leadership, on the
contrary, I think it is simply getting stronger,
but that gives us more
work because we have to
reconcile, if I may say so,
convergence in our countries and the
ability to build compromises and the
ability to build these compromises then
at European level that's what we
will do with a lot of heart, will
and optimism
[Music]
this
deficit in one life
[Music]
to
fail
too  partisan
to
soan
soan destatis
the
bbc m
for
example
while
those
[Music]
of the energy pole
the gas gas gas in this
windows seven file
said to myself 'I end of the seven will see what is
positive and gengis offsets possible to
propose your unit  especially if he
continues to which had and yes with life
I first have possible collateral fx
the evenings it we try
16 to be sure to be done yes we do
not feel
that a visit decidir
appropriate said  we have  re coming days
the
[Music]
sound of course
we exclude
liliane bettencourt this attack in
global crisis of scpi disk acted alone
we will end with anne at 9 years old
every ask us a question
thank you yes anne rovan au figaro I have two
questions  of 3 but fairly quick the
first is on the
European political community
how do you see things you are
talking about a meeting so under the
presidency every
good we know that I imagine that the
balkans the countries of the western balkans
will be will be there
we can  to think that ukraine
moldova georgia are represented but you
how are you going to do for the other
countries to what you have launched is what
you are going to launch invitations so this
is the first question the second
question it is on the
political situation in france
you explained everything to us so finally
the few minutes that basically
france was in a situation
finally was in the process of normalization
so that means that it  there is no
taboo
vis-à-vis your counterparts
have you discussed the subject
with certain new counterparts who
are familiar with the difficulties of
building majorities, etc. and then a
question for you, Ms. von der leyen
and
mr charles michel do you
think that the political situation in
france could slow down the course
of europe here is
me i am i am extremely
confident and extremely optimistic it has
been indicated and then whoever is talking to you has
some experiences in a country which
is not the simplest in terms
of institutional and
democratic organization and then perhaps to
do something about what was
indicated I think that we have been able to demonstrate
throughout the last few months the
leadership of the European Union has
capacities to remain united this was
described in particular throughout the
last six months audrey this
french presence which was a cleric success
it is a success because in spite of
circumstances  tances extremely difficult
there was an opportunity to accelerate an agenda
an ambition of sovereignty
and strategic autonomy to identify
what are the common interests and what
are the subjects on which there is a
will even in themes which are
mainly themes
to move forward together, this is the case
with energy, this is the case
with defense security, for
example, I won't go over the long list
of advances that have been made over
the past two months, so
there really is a
great confidence also great confidence that our
democratic models which actually it's
just crazy rise to a certain number
of elements of criteria of factors to be
taken into consideration two
institutional realities of quality
political sensitivities social
important roles for civil societies
this  are political systems
that guarantee we think it very
very sincerely it directly affects
our  fundamental values
this adhesion and this confidence
citizens that we permanently we must
go to the driveway to conquer
it it requires permanent efforts there is
this great confidence that I want to
express that throughout
the coming months and years the
strong european union of its member states
to national democracies are
well aware of the challenges
we face
so we know that we can
france members
experience
on your two questions which concerned me
the second we are constantly talking
with colleagues about models  policies
of what they have done so obviously
permanently with the main colleagues
I follow their political life who
follow ours things are different
because we do not have the same
political culture they are structured
differently and and despite everything even if
in  france there is in parliament today
a relative majority it appears to
be very important compared to  ort to
many other parliamentary systems
with a pure proportional system if we
look at all proportions we
often owe germany at the moment to a
coalition with three partners
so see that's to say all that shows the
systems are very different one
the other but we are always inspired by
things and after my fall always struck
in our domestic political debates
France knows how to compromise
and including yours truly we spend
our lives doing it here we spend our
lives building solutions with  people
who have who disinterest who
sensitivities that are not ours
to build texts and decisions
why would we be unable
to do so in an assembly with
women and men insofar as they
have different sensitivities but are
are part of the republican field
and the will to govern to
move the country forward, so I am very
confident because I believe in
goodwill  women and men
who are there to represent the nation
and so I think things
will move forward, but once again with a
model that is slightly different
depending on the country in the
European political community, we are going to do things
very simply, we  going to do the reverse,
everything that generally hasn't
worked, that is to say, build
entities before knowing where you are
coming from and without people
all being around the table,
so the strategic intuition
that I pose European Parliament  last May 9
gave rise to exchanges a
lot of work by our ambassadors
of a sherpa we had a
long session yesterday and we shared I believe
a strategic conviction
it is from intuition to the conviction
that we had  need
to have an
exchange working forum,
perhaps moreover, to structure more on
all these subjects
in this European space sharing the
same values ​​and therefore what do we
we are going to do we are going to prepare
with President Michel and the Prime
Minister there is a list of subjects and
then all the colleagues who want to
get involved have discussed a list of subjects which
seem to us to be of general interest
and we are going to invite
from Iceland  to ukraine,
i.e. countries which are in the
european economic area countries which have
recently left the european union
countries which aspire to become countries of the
western balkans which are not
yet recognized as having the status
candidates from the so-called
eastern partnership countries which are candidates now
or with prospects or not here and
simply we are going to borders and simple things
eastern the border will pass
to the east of our european union
including, if I may say so, ukraine and
moldova here I say that because there have
been other attempts where we go
much further and which moreover
contributed to their failure
worst of you rightly we do
r  reference to the
european confederation which had been
launched
the story is always ironic
since it had been launched at vaclav
havel by françois mitterrand but it
was at that time a bit of a substitute for
enlargement
and it was resolutely inclusive
for russia which we do not  we have not
proposed
so here is this geographical framework I believe
will make us invite
these countries around the table and we
will have this discussion is the idea
then centa is that we can
ritualize it and gradually structure it
I believe  that this is the method
that reached consensus yesterday and which allows us
to move forward in a very pragmatic way
thank you very much sir crisis have won
everyone thank you very much thank you
m
[Music]